by some strange technological and  philosophical osmosis we can create a  universal moral framework that can be  accepted by Every Soul on this planet we  negotiate and debate and exchange verbal  Tantrums in an attempt to defend our  point of view and our position in the  dominance hierarchy of society some  people do that in a more ethical way and  in order to defend the goodness but most  just keep perpetuating by now attitudes  and approaches and it is this banality  and triviality of existence that needs  to be dealt with in order to identify  what is morally good actually it is the  combination of this and the ability to  Showcase common sense in the face of  trivial matters with common sense the  discovery of a solution to most of our  problems could be accelerated  dramatically all it takes is to offer  Clarity to our judgment and Common Sense  is imperative in that respect especially  when it comes to orienting ourselves  towards what is morally good